hello Doug Walker here and I'm gonna
talk about the artist didn't achieve my
voice I almost lost it this week so it's
still a little a little squeaky but
hopefully it'll be better by the time I
do the end see hopefully fingers crossed
um and I'm really just doing this
because there's a bummer view up and it
really the only reason I did the bummer
view is because I always want to do a
bummer review silence do you know sort
of as a a silent film so I figure the
artist was the perfect chance to try
that so I don't know if you really wanna
know what I think of this movie but I'll
tell you I know I'll put it out there
because most people are just saying yeah
it's great it's a good movie and that's
pretty much it it is a good movie it's a
plot real fast is a it's a very clever
plot we get down to it it's a silent
film about how silent films are going
into sound and how there you can hear
people talk and so forth um but the
angle this takes that I realized I don't
think any film is done yet is the impact
it has on a lot of the actors because a
lot of actors could not make the
transition into talking films and it
ruined a lot of careers I mean some
people made it fine you know especially
the comedians like a chaplain may find
that the three stooges made fine uh but
there's a lot of actors that could not
particularly the serious actors had a
very rough time making that transition
and this film is about that and it's
done well it's done very much in that
silent film style and storytelling and
it is very clever the main actor is very
entertaining as this great smile reminds
me a lot Phil Hartman at Jay's hamster
that similar smile um the actress that
they got who sort of becomes bigger than
him it was very entertaining as well and
she was a lot of fun and I like the fact
that they sort of the the actress in
this movie starts to get a little bigger
than him in terms of Fame and they serve
playing when it starts to go to her head
a little bit but it's like that's not it
it doesn't stop there it's like she's
more of a human being than just that
because a lot of people they have it
that they get big and then they're just
snobby and then they throughout the
movie they learn that lesson like that's
all there was that character but I like
the fact they've really made this
character that you know she was on her
high horse for a bit but she's very
quickly knocked out and I think that
does happen I mean people can learn
their lessons very quickly and I like
the fact that I do sort of reference
then how they address it you know when
she served back down the high horse I
thought was very effective it was very
smart um I'm trying to think outside
that it's such a basic story sort of the
you know rags to riches back to rags
almost when he's already famous Oh mate
just riches to rags um
and it's it's clever it's funny it's
smart it's dramatic a lot of dramatic
moments actually are very effective
despite the fact that you know it's
supposed to be a little over the top you
know like a silent film is um trying to
think what else the use of sound in this
moment here here's what I thought they
were gonna do I thought maybe this would
have been more clever I wouldn't mind
seeing a film that tries this there
actually is a little bit of talking this
will be a little bit of sound and what I
thought they were going to do was I
thought that as talking films came into
production and we're getting bigger and
bigger and this actor is getting tossed
more and more to the side I thought the
world around him was gonna start
literally talking like using their
voices and he was going to remain silent
because he couldn't make the transition
that would be awesome
I love to see a film that tries that so
I like what Pleasantville did with the
colors and the black and white I'll
start hoping they go that route but then
it's like it's just sort of a dream and
there's a little talking at the end and
it works it's good I mean but it's like
oh wait I wanted to see that but I'm one
of those jerks and always says oh would
it be cool they did that and it's a long
reviewing reviewing what isn't for what
is it's a good movie it's uh it's sort
of what you think it's gonna be but it's
still addressing an issue then I don't
know how many films have really talked
about
like I said I mean there's been several
films like singing in the rain talking
about going from silent films to talking
films but not one like this where it
shows just what a negative impact it did
happen a lot of people too so yeah I
definitely really enjoyed it I thought
it was a lot of fun and yeah if it looks
like something you enjoy go see it I
think the only people that wouldn't like
it maybe the people that can sort of see
the plot coming and just aren't
interested in that kind of story but it
is told it's sort of a different way so
it's a little bit more of the style but
the story's decent is to it we kind of
seen it but it's it's still about
subject that hasn't been talked about in
this way um and I guess other people
baby pilla just don't like silent films
but I think even a lot of people that
don't like silent films would find
themselves surprisingly sort of getting
into this so that's really about in
terms of who I think probably wouldn't
like it I think a lot of people would
enjoy it because it is kind of universal
you can dump it in any language because
you can just put whatever language you
want in the title cards so uh I can see
why it's doing so well why so many
people like it and it it's a decent
movie so if you want to see really
creative really different kind of film
go check out the artists that's it
take care